tout de suite retrouvez l'actualité de
la semaine
retour en images sur les principaux
événements du département pour tous ces
étudiants le bac encore le brevet des
collèges c'est gagné et la bibliothèque
départementale a fait honneur aux
diplômés et plus particulièrement aux
bacheliers depuis maintenant trois ans
la bd r change ses horaires d'ouverture
et de fermeture pour permettre aux
lycéens de terminale de réviser plus
longtemps des annales sont également
mises à leur disposition
c'est la troisième année qu'on met en
place ce dispositif pour aider les
étudiants a réussi en avantage
d'ailleurs il ya eu plus de 3500
étudiants sur 20 jours on met des livres
à leur disposition et puis on les
accueille dans les encourage des
révisions plus tardive des révisions
groupe ou seul à chacun sa formule une
formule payante puisque 100 % des
étudiants qui sont venus à la
bibliothèque cette année ont réussi leur
baccalauréat
ça nous a permis de nous retrouver en
groupe d'échanger nos connaissances avec
ceux qui n avaient pas forcément et de
s'entraider sur toute sa science tout ça
c'était mes révisions en même temps les
ouvrages et en même temps les
expositions qui était présentée ici qui
m'ont attiré et franchement c'est un
endroit agréable reposant et pour
réviser votre bac c'est l'endroit
parfait je trouve très calme personne
vous dérange et tout le monde et
accueillons ici
une cérémonie qui a été aussi l'occasion
de proposer aux futurs étudiants les
dispositifs d'être mise en place par le
conseil départemental sur le site les
bois c'est donc les étudiants
s'inscrivent donc nous donner à cette un
nombre d'informations ils vont confirmer
le projet à la rentrée universitaire par
l'envoi de cette nombre de pièces donc
notamment le certificat de scolarité et
nous allons déclencher dans la par la
suite donc les différents paiements que
ce soit la gauche- la location de
scolarité un cocktail et un cadeau pour
récompenser l'assiduité de ses étudiants
qui garderont un souvenir précis de leur
bac et de la manière dont ils ont pu
obtenir leur diplôme
le conseil départemental et la région
réunion ont célébré ce dimanche 10
juillet la fête de l'aïd qui marque la
fin du mois sacré de ramadhan à la villa
du département
nous avons choisi plutôt de garder le
modèle réunionnais qui transmet le vivre
ensemble
moi je suis indienne de confession
musulmane
les deux petites antilles comme ils
savent à l'église avec une bonne
camarade comme ils savent à la messe
comme ça va lancer à mon camarade
tamouls
damian crohn à connaître comment l'autre
ville c'est quoi sa foi ou même salon
soit moi j'ai des amis qui sont athées
c'est ce vivre ensemble à qu'ils ne
trouvent pas peur de la réunion parce
que il représente l'idéal français
républicain que nous avons bien que
étant chinoise d'origine mais ayant vécu
avec dans toute ma famille avec une
mélange de religion le bouddhisme
chrétien et je trouve tout à fait normal
qu'à la réunion on puisse pour voir
célébrer les fêtes de notre communauté
qui composent également notre terroir
notre terrain réunionnaise plus petits
blancs nous avons ici un islam paisible
une flamme qui a trouvé ici un terrain
pour s'épanouir
la célébration de l'aïd
comme la célébration des deux fêtes sont
des moments de partage et c'est ça qui
est l'heureux qui fait l'originalité de
la rue nous c'est la part faite
l'ensemble des de la diversité à la fois
culturelle et spirituelle chacun un
certain diverses animations étaient
mises en place telles que la
calligraphie le henné mais aussi des
ateliers boutiques pour les enfants la
fête de l'aïd à la villa du département
reflète bien l'esprit de partage si
important pour les musulmans durant ce
mois sacré
organisé sur le barachois le défilé du
14 juillet à saint denis
le corps de sapeurs pompiers réunionnais
n'a pas dérogé à la règle en ce 14
juillet 2016
les hommes du feu étaient présents
traditionnel défilé parmi ses troupes
les jeunes sapeurs pompiers également
mise à l'honneur sur le barachois pour
le défilé du 14 juillet nous avons
mobilisé l'ensemble des troupes
représentative justice notamment
une section départementale des sapeurs
pompiers la formation initiale il
s'accomplit jeunes c'est complet qui
viennent de rentrer une section de
jeunes sapeurs pompiers qui est en
formation également ainsi que une
section spécialisée qui est le délit h
et les bac pro qui est une section de
l'école pas tous heureusement fin du
lycée patu des heureusement pour un
total de 134 défilant nintendogs du
sdiss réunion a eu l'honneur de
participer à la parade nationale devant
le chef de l'état il y as depuis
maintenant sept huit ans un bataillon
france qui est créé chaque année au
niveau national pour représenter les
pompiers civils lors du défilé du 14
juillet de cette année c'est donc tout
l'outre-mer qui
il est chargé de représenter et de l'île
de la réunion qui a été chargé de
piloter cette affaire et donc il y aura
25 savon au pied réunionnais sur les 80
qui vont défiler les vice-présidents
voulu rendre hommage à l'engagement des
militaires mais aussi à nos sapeurs
pompiers et pour nous c'est l'occasion
d' avant de penser à nos militaires et
notamment réunionnais qui participera à
travers les forces françaises aux
différentes actions
il y en a même qui ont laissé leur vie
dont quelques parents voudraient leur
rendre hommage à nos militaires et au
bras ce qui est bien sûr vie des
réunionnais et c'est aussi l'occasion de
montrer que le département la région
mais moi toute sa place dans les mesures
de sécurité pour notre département
justement à travers par exemple 6 et on
a vu défiler des personnels du stis on
avait du matériel que le département
finance est bien pour nous c'est notre
façon à nous de participer à la
protection civile et à la protection des
biens mais surtout des personnes ici à
la réunion
le défilé du 14 juillet a également été
l'occasion pour le représentant de
l'état de décor et plusieurs militaires
de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur